בפרק הזה נחקור
איך מחשבים קוונטיים וקלאסיים
עובדים יחד כדי לפתור אחד האתגרים החשובים ביותר
במדע - הערכה מדויקת של האנרגיה של מולקולות וחומרים
אנחנו יכולים להשיג את זה
באמצעות שימוש ב-circuit קוונטי
כדי לייצר דוגמאות של בסיס
שאותן נעבד לאחר מכן
ונבצע דיאגונליזציה באמצעות מספר אלגוריתמים
במשפחת השגרות הזו
כמו SQV ו-SKG, ויש קורס שלם על
פלטפורמת IBM Quantum המוקדשת
להם ולשיטות קשורות
למטרות שלנו בחלק הזה
נשאיר את ההסבר קצר
בין אם אתם משתמשים ב-SQV או ב-SKG
המטרה שלכם היא למצוא וקטורים עצמיים
וערכים עצמיים עבור מטריצת המילטוניאן
המטריצה הזו עשויה לתאר את האנרגיה של מערכת פיזית
או כימית, אבל אותה מסגרת
יכולה לטפל בהרבה סוגי בעיות אחרים
כמו לוגיסטיקה. לפעמים
המטריצות האלו הן עצומות
אז צמצום הממדים
של המטריצה תוך שמירה על מאפיינים חשובים
של מצב היסוד
יכול להיות בעל ערך רב - זו המטרה ב-SQV
אנחנו משתמשים במחשב הקוונטי כדי לייצר תת-מרחב שימושי
כזה שמכיל את מצב היסוד
אנחנו יכולים אז להטיל את מטריצת ההמילטוניאן שלנו
על תת-המרחב הזה, מה שמשאיר אותנו
עם מטריצה קטנה יותר שתהיה
הרבה יותר קלה לדיאגונליזציה
באמצעות מחשוב קלאסי בביצועים גבוהים. אנחנו עושים זאת
על ידי הכנת מצב קוונטי ניסויי
שנקרא לרוב אנסץ'
וביצוע מדידות לדגימה של האנסץ'
בבסיס החישובי, מה שנותן לנו
תת-מרחב מדגם בבסיס החישובי
אבל מה שבאמת רוצים למצוא
הוא מצב היסוד האמיתי. מה
אם תת-המרחב המדגם שלנו לא הכיל
את כל הרכיבים הנחוצים
אם נבחר אנסץ' טוב יותר
אולי נקבל הערכה טובה יותר של מצב היסוד
זה מביא אותנו לאלגוריתם מבוסס דגימות
לאלכסון קוונטי, או SKUDY. ב-SKUDY
אנחנו מתחילים עם אנסץ'
כמו קודם, אבל אז מיישמים כמה gate-ים קוונטיים שמקרבים
את התפתחות הזמן של מערכת פיזית
אפשר להראות שעם כמה הנחות
זה מוביל לערבויות על החפיפה בין התפתחות הזמן
של האנסץ' ומצב היסוד האמיתי
שני האלגוריתמים האלה מתחילים עם מטריצת
המילטוניאן עצומה, הם עובדים קצת שונה
אבל בשני המקרים החלק הקוונטי של האלגוריתם מניב
תת-מרחב שמאפשר לנו לצמצם את המטריצה שלנו
ובו אנחנו מקווים לשמר את המאפיינים המרכזיים של מצב היסוד
אז איפה נכנס מחשוב קלאסי בביצועים גבוהים
עבור ההמילטוניאנים הגדולים ביותר
ועבור ההערכות המדויקות ביותר של מצב היסוד
גם המטריצות המוטלות האלה יכולות להיות די גדולות
לכן מינוף יכולות מחשוב קלאסי חזקות יותר
יכול לעזור לנו לא
רק לקבל תוצאות טובות יותר
אלא גם לאפשר לנו להתמודד עם בעיות גדולות יותר
כדי לחבר הכל יחד
אנחנו יכולים לייצג אלגוריתמים מבוססי דגימות
כשילוב של מודלי תכנות שונים
על מערכת של משאבים היברידיים
לדוגמה, אנחנו יכולים לייצג את האלגוריתם שלנו
כתהליך עבודה של משימות, שבו יש לנו משימה
להכנת circuit קוונטי שחופף
עם המצב הרצוי, ואחריה משימה
לטרנספורמציה שדורשת רק משאבים קלאסיים
להרצה. בשלב הבא תהיה המשימה
שמשתמשת ב-primitives להרצת ה-circuit הקוונטי שלנו
שברור שתצטרך
ואז יהיה לנו משימת עיבוד לאחר מכן שבפני עצמה
עשויה להיות אלגוריתם דיאגונליזציה מקבילי
שרץ על מספר צמתים
בנוסף, אולי נרצה להריץ
את אחד האלגוריתמים האלה פעמים רבות
בזמן שאנחנו משנים את האנסץ' שלנו
או להריץ אותם במקביל לגמרי
עם פרמטרים שונים
עכשיו בואו נחבר הכל עם SKUDY
בקוד. הנה כל קבצי המשימות שלנו
והנה כל קבצי ה-submission שלנו
במשימת המיפוי אנחנו מכינים circuit-ים.
בשלב האופטימיזציה אנחנו מריצים את ה-circuit-ים בצורה הטובה ביותר.
במשימת ההרצה אנחנו דוגמים ביטסטרינגים
מהמצב שהוכן על ידי
ה-circuit ה-ISA שלנו.
שקיבלנו מהשלב הקודם
ואנחנו מבצעים את העיבוד שלאחר מכן.
אז עכשיו אנחנו מוכנים לשלוח את
תהליך העבודה שלנו.
כמו שאפשר לראות, הכל כתוב ברצף
עם תלויות. בואו נחכה
לתוצאות ונוכל לבדוק את קבצי הפלט שלנו.
הנה קובץ הפלט של שלב האופטימיזציה
שבו יש לנו את ה-circuit ה-ISA שלנו.
ולבסוף בואו נבדוק את ה-
איטרציה שלנו.
מהלוח הזמנים.
וזה הכל לגבי ההדגמה הקצרה של תהליך העבודה של SKUDY
כל הקוד יהיה זמין בחלק הטקסט
או בתיאור למטה
וזה הכל - עברנו על כמה
קונספטים ודוגמאות שיכולים לעזור לכם להתחיל עם
ניהול תוכניות היברידיות מורכבות. כמובן
אם אתם אוהבים את זה, זה רק מגרד את פני השטח של
כל מה שאפשר לעשות עם השילוב של קוונטי
ומשאבים קלאסיים ספציפיים. כדי לחקור עוד
בדקו את התיעוד והמדריכים
על פלטפורמת IBM Quantum
ובטוח תבדקו את המשאבים ששותפו בחלק הטקסט
או בתיאור לפריטים נוספים
ותוכנה. תודה שצפיתם.
כן, זהו.